football is his big love and javis
chokotto is really good at it afternoon
practice at the soccer club the boys
here were all discovered because they
had a lot of talent that includes 17
year-old javis after the warm-up it's
time for the next round javis is a
midfielder he's responsible for strategy
the other players have to be able to
depend on him today it's extremely hot
but practice continues just a short
break for a drink of water the players
have to have discipline and plenty of
stamina attending of not a physical
feeding his practice helps us keep
physically fit so that we don't get
tired easily on the pitch it also helps
us to be focused and work hard which can
be decisive in a match very very strong
oh and a girl
his home is on the other side of the
hill in Fonda an outlying district of
Blantyre it's a disadvantaged
neighborhood conditions here are bad
tens of thousands of people live in
close quarters life is hard and even the
bare necessities are lacking but Jabez
doesn't let himself get discouraged is
my home and that's my mother
she sells charcoal to earn some money
for the family I learned my soccer
skills from play soccer Malawi play
soccer Malawi is the project that gave
him a new horizon it's opened doors for
javis paving the way to recognition and
a better education there's a large
soccer pitch right nearby it's the home
of play soccer Malawi javis was once one
of these children
Silas lawenda manages the program he
still knows javis very well from the
time when he came here regularly to
learn and to play football
Java's proved himself a hard worker from
the very start he joined when he was
barely eight he was very ambitious and
he became very confident in his
abilities not only in football but in
classes as well he improved quite
quickly he was deeply dedicated to go to
[ __ ] him and his soccer skills made him
a local celebrity jabus is a role model
for many of the kids here but the focus
isn't only on soccer soccer is only what
gets them here it's about getting the
children to learn something instead of
just hanging out in the street
lots of kids here especially from the
poor neighborhoods quit school much too
early today diet and nutrition are on
the lesson plan the teacher tells the
children how important vegetables and
fish are if you can choose what you eat
after sitting and listening they get to
play soccer today Emily Josiah is
coaching them she too was long a member
of play soccer Malawi now she's a
successful footballer herself even
playing in tournaments abroad and she's
waiting for a place at university here
she's playing along so she can give
something back
not from the noise up position is from
the money I coach these kids so that
they can get what I had from play soccer
Malawi I got a scholarship to school and
I want them to have that opportunity as
well before the children leave there's
another important part of the program
something to eat today - bread rolls
Silas the project manager reminds the
children to be careful and hide the
bread under their shirts so it won't be
stolen on their way home by other
children who aren't part of the program
early the next morning teenagers from
all around Inder Andy flock to school
schibetta has made it to secondary
school thanks to a recommendation from
play soccer Malawi and great
the pupils have to get their own chairs
javis and his classmates are on time but
the teacher is late that's typical in
Malawi the educational system is
inadequate teachers are often paid too
late and then simply don't turn up today
these kids have had to wait until
finally a substitute stepped in it's
important not to cut classes both for
students and teachers because we have a
lot to learn only if we get a decent
education can we aim for a brighter
future a short breakfast break school
isn't out yet certainly not for jobless
but more than anything he has his future
career in mind becoming a great soccer
player